[Musique]
contre les ti est l'alpha et une
différence dans le rapide et de la
douceur on va dire que la fois va cacher
sa douceur vin cacher parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de loups autour d'elle les tirs
les tirs
je peux de résoudre mais termine tout le
monde je ne ferai pas preuve d'humilité
vu qu'ici pas tout le monde ce père j'ai
mis de côté mes sentiments et mon
humanité ne viens pas me parler de
charité
la plupart des paroles de la halle face
à moi qui les ai écrites près j'ai été
beaucoup en collaboration avec son
vraiment il m'a beaucoup beaucoup appris
avec lui ça vraiment beaucoup match et
ce que j'aime beaucoup c'est que ça
rappe brut qui renferme beaucoup
d'émotion si tu veux mon jeu comporte
souvent la fin un diamant brut ou faire
attention à le polir pour vraiment
sortir les meilleurs éléments et c'est
ce qui m'a plu à travailler avec elle
parce que c'est une boule d'énergie et
même quand tu la vois quand tu parles
est là toute cette énergie elle qui sort
et le challenge était justement de
prendre les bonnes énergies au bon
moment pour bien justement la mettre en
valeur en étant studieux et on est parti
de ces textes à elle c'est vraiment un
travail ensemble
ce
que j'apporte et c'est est ce que l
avais en tête mais qu'elle n'arrivait
pas forcément à sortir et là quand
arrive un level où justement tu dois
faire comprendre aux gens qui sont
durables qui ne sont pas du rap à aimer
le rap fin certaine manière certaines
choses qu'il faut faire ressortir plus
que d'autres une question de timing
aussi même des timings musicale et et
c'est super intéressante avec elle
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est chez fifou et c'est
une scène d'un vin chaud de photos un
peu particulier pour des raisons un peu
particulière
[Musique]
jambes avec sa
moustache
pour canapé bleu c'est quelque chose
qu'on a coécrit c'est comme si je
rentrais dans sa tête et je suis me suis
mis à sa place en fait
c'est un moment auquel je tenais
beaucoup je suis complètement à
l'initiative de cette idée j'ai compris
que les auteurs qu'il fallait qu'on
parle de la puissance de la méchanceté
de l'aspect néfastes de la violence des
réseaux sociaux et surtout de cette
triste réalité que un bad buzz est
toujours plus événementielle qui a un
goût de buzz
égard on va pas tarder à faire la photo
donc si vous pouvez nous attendent or
s'il vous plaît ça serait cool et
on va sur les réseaux sociaux chercher
des mauvaises nouvelles on va on peut
voir des gens qui tombent voir des gens
qui se blesse on veut pas voir des gens
qui sont heureux et je voulais raconter
ce que ça pouvait provoquer chez une
nana qui arrive dans ce game qui avait
déjà des réticences à redevenir rappeuse
parce que c'est que c'est très dur et
puis elle a ses casseroles et puis il ya
les complexités de tout ça on fait comme
si on t'aime on fait comme si on a envie
d'écouter des morceaux
mais on va se jeter sur la première bad
news qui qui qui tombe
le talent ça peuple je fais deux fois
plus debout quand tu crois que tu sois
fier il faut tu préfères pas compter
pour rameuter le public j'ai dû être
tracté texte explique j'ai voulu
raconter une scène où notre héroïne
aller avec l'aide de william qui a
qualité principale
comment ensemble ils vont réussir à
s'associer en une nuit pour faire d'un
bad buzz un goût de buzz comment est-ce
qu'ils vont mettre le nez dans la merde
des gens voilà c'est ça que je voulais
montrer
[Musique]
pourquoi
référence et stromae quand je travaille
les chutes et il ya quelques années une
vidéo de lui complètement bourré dans
les rues de bruxelles ou la malveillance
des gens sur les réseaux sociaux
se jette sur cette vidéo avec joie
regarde il est bourré regarde c'est la
décadence regarde la honte et que deux
jours après et explique que c'était pour
un clip et c'est un des plus gros
morceau de sa carrière et il a
tout le monde en disant regardez comme
vous êtes méchant
[Musique]
on peut pas faire une série dans le rap
où on sait que le ya une partie du
public du rap font partie des plus dures
des plus virulents sur les réseaux
sociaux sans qu'on fasse un petit appel
de phares en disant regardez parfois
prenons quelques instants pour se poser
la question du mal que ça fait à la
personne concernée c'est le moment où de
façon le plus évidente dans la série
elle décide de ne plus être victimes et
la façon qu est la réponse est justement
pas en victimes qui sont agressés mais
elle reprend les rênes de son dessin et
ça je pense que c'est super important
c'est magnifique
dans la trajectoire de ce personnage
summum de la bêtise humaine respecter
plein d'abonnés alors qu'en fait tu t'es
qu'une merde alors qu'en fait quelques
herbes tous prêts à regarder tout ça
commence en savoie samantha trop sage ou
les juges une bande de roulage mais je
vous rappelle que je suis la crise j'ai
bien compris tu pour faire le buzz pour
alerter les buts à quel coût je dois
faire réagir la plèbe les photos sont
allongés sur un canapé bhl c'est en a
pas eu assez il reste quoi dans les
chiottes avait pourtant longtemps que
j'obtiens de terre cuite oups après vers
de terre est devenue un papillon est
donc la dernière séquence des hip hop
symphonie c'est le papillon
[Musique]
c'est magique parce que oui c'est un
morceau très important c'est le morceau
final de l'épisode 9 et c'est vraiment
une délivrance pour elle parce que elle
devient une femme elle s'accomplit en
tant qu rappeuse
c'est un peu une consécration pour elle
et se sont se sont amenés à la liberté
c'est vraiment un morceau à l est de le
voir en symphonie pour elle c'est est un
c'est une première de jouer avec un
orchestre symphonique
et se trouve fort parce qu'elle a réussi
à s'adapter et sur l'instru et en rap
contenders est maintenant en orchestre
symphonique est l'ami du laëtitia dans
l'alpha de la faim dans laëtitia est ce
qui fait que ce morceau et il est
particulier
plus promnog sûr on dit qu'on a la
version qui est on à la version vide là
où l'on fait la version
rencontre
avec m du coup un chef d'orchestre issam
krimi grand chef d'orchestre donc voilà
quarante violons derrière tout plein
d'instruments c'est cette scène à
l'écran 12 et pour les rappeurs se il ya
des moments où quand tu entends d'instru
ça sort tout seul c'était forcément ça
qui est c'était ça
si je suis là ce soir
c'est grâce à william est brune d'apache
musique cette fin c'est le début de la
nouvelle vie de la femme merci mes
frères
nf ou merci c'est grâce à toi tout a
commencé
merci
photo massa on se sait on alliés pas
besoin de parler on se connaît mais
remontons rappeuse tout ce que j'espère
c'est que la visibilité que j'ai eu
moins dans cette série qui parle de
rabat ça pourra donner plein de force à
toutes les autres rappeuse dj ce nom le
magicien bon magicien j'espère qu'on va
continuer à faire de grandes choses
ensemble
ton travail merci dans la vie mon
analyse c'est que ya une place à prendre
il ya une place pour une femme ou
peut-être même dès lors plusieurs qui
arriveront et qui qui raconteront
surtout leur histoire leurs fêlures
leurs blessures et puis qui rentreront
là dedans dans la compétition donc il ya
un vrai challenge et c'est pas fermé il
faut leur dire qu'elles viennent si
elles ont envie de rap et il faut pas
avoir peur de rap et
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on est une
femme qui rappe merveilleusement bien
qui rappe comme un homme mais à qui on
dit les femmes ça marche pas moi j'ai
décidé de parler d'une femme dans rap à
qui on dit tout le temps ça marche pas
et qui elle veut dire vous verrez quoi
ça va marcher je suis convaincu d'une
chose aujourd'hui tu manques on se parle
c'est que ça va marcher pour elle dans
la série mais dans la vraie vie ça va
marcher aussi
mais
j'ai préparé un stade parfait la pelouse
est parfaite le public est là maintenant
il faut qu'elle fasse un grand match
dessus elle m'a déjà fait un grand match
pendant le tournage je sais que cette
saison va marquer les gens parce qu'elle
a envoyé à l'image et puis le reste du
match après il est sur moi mais en tout
cas j'ai bien préparé le terrain foyer
on va de tout le monde
[Musique]
profitez de la fiche
à la nuit quand la nuit là ma limite
ap
m
moi je traîne sceptiques
les
ce qui était important sur cette saison
2 c'était que je clôture quelque chose
je n'ai pas encore mon onze par l'idée
de la saison 3 n'est pas question
d'entamer une saison 3 tant que j'ai pas
une idée forte et des convictions de
faire quelque chose de puissant
je peux très bien dire ok moi j'arrête
validé mais je laisse des gens de faire
à ma place
et je vais parler c'est à faire ça
[Musique]
à